there's something called dunning-kruger
where the idea is that people
dramatically overestimate their
competence and people at higher levels
of aptitude underestimate their
confidence my favorite way to see this
play out in real life is if you ask
somebody hey do you speak Spanish and
somebody's like yeah I speak a pretty
decent amount 99 of the time somebody
gives an answer like that is they took
like to Spanish three in high school and
they're like donde El bibliotech or
whatever my mom is a good example if I
asked my mom like Mom how good is your
Spanish she'll be like ah it's like it's
okay my mom is a fluent Spanish speaker
she just doesn't know some technical
terms